i mentioned the show to you luther which
stars idris elba it's a detective show
set in the uk done by the bbc fantastic
show it's got five seasons apparently
they're doing a movie
great acting performances and race is
not
it's not really mentioned it's uk [ __ ]
okay it's just good television
and there's plenty of black characters
but race is not really a thing there
okay
so some of them sent me this article and
this happened late early on this year
and someone wrote an article said idris
albus luther was not black enough to be
real bbc's chief diversity officer says
the uk cop doesn't have any black
friends he doesn't eat caribbean food
miranda wayland said during an industry
conference
i gotta show you i'm drinking
a [ __ ] i i i have to show you oh yeah
yeah while i'm enjoying this
what i'm enjoying this jamaican party
let's go figure out what's going on over
there oh yeah i'll finish those five but
first i got to get me curie going
it's not organic i just don't man i
don't mention everything excuse me
officer do you have a warrant we not
have that
it seems like this homosexual individual
was shot and killed we found out who
who what when
batman nothing
a man died okay
me not care if a sodomite died may not
care about that
test clause yes we know i need if you
search for that you're here yes chaos
closed when luther first came out
everybody loved the fact that idris ibo
was in there a really strong black
character lead
we all fell in love with him who didn't
write but after he got about the second
series you got to
kind of like okay he doesn't have any
black friends he doesn't need caribbean
food this doesn't feel authentic
oh my god bruh and that's the chief
diversity officer and this is what
happens when you create these like
positions in workplaces for diversity it
ends up just being coming like how can
we make y'all fit these stereotypes
listen not every black person is going
to have a bunch of black friends not
every black person is going to eat
caribbean food okay not all of them are
going to have like a strong connection
to their motherland and that's okay that
that proves the fact that we're not
monolithic okay some people are going to
fit the stereotypes right they're going
to be cops but they go back to the hood
because they grew up with a bunch of
nicks and some of them grew up in the
suburbs because they were adopted or
they come from a rich black family it
varies bro but everybody tries to
shoehorn themselves into these positions
because they think that that's the only
way it works that's why you got rappers
who've never spent a day in the hood
rapping about shooting and robbing
people
they their parents are [ __ ]
executives at sony stop lying cory larae
yes
she's out here talking crazy i'm like
daughter of benzino you grew up in a in
a gated community like what is you
smoking
yeah yeah we shoot we shooting over the
gates hey [ __ ] get the keypad bruh what
are you talking about
yo
[Music]
and they try to shoehorn us into these
positions and if we don't conform
there's something wrong right
if you're a black person who doesn't say
the word naked then you're weird right
or if you
um act you start talking white you speak
white like everything is
if you don't conform you're not black
enough what they're really saying in
that moment is
if you don't fit to this
well you're not stereotypically black
enough
uh-huh i'd like for us to just get to a
point where other than the pigmentation
that we have and maybe some cultural
elements from the shared history it
really isn't that deep but these folks
want every character who's on the
television who happens to be black to
eat jerk chicken to have strong
caribbean types to always fit the mold
and it gets to be a little bit redundant
so let me get this chain
uh
they trying to fight
these stereotypes because they don't
like stereotypes
with more stereotypes that's how it
works it's funny because me and i don't
remember the last time i had caribbean
food you know why because i try to i try
to eat healthy now watch them go crazy
all right but it is what it is at the
end of the day if you look at my diet i
don't eat i don't often eat caribbean
food just because of that because i eat
it at my mom and even my mom's trying to
take care of like i eat at my mom
because i know everything's safe out
there you know what i mean she's trying
to take care of yeah her health
so i'm not going to be out there always
like it much every day you eat a potty
every day you eat rising any
can i have a salad sometimes yeah it's
like
more stereotypes of fight stereotypes
it's weird yeah whatever neil cross the
creator who's white of the show luther
said listen
i have no knowledge or expertise or
right to try to tackle in some way the
black experience of a black man in
modern britain i just wrote a character
and
the actor who played him happen to be
black i'm like
thank you thank you not every story on
television that involves a black
character has to involve their race or
their culture
this is meritocracy at its finest there
was a character rin he happened to be
the best actor he got it you got the
part she's not black enough i want you
to read on
what she says this her reply waylon
argued that it's not enough to just have
a black character in the lead and think
that's enough for diversity
it's great having those big landmark
shows with those key characters
but it's about making sure that
everything around them their environment
their culture that set is absolutely
reflective
it will be very much about how we can
make sure that the program is authentic
in terms of storytelling i understand
where they're coming from with this
because sometimes you do get parts and
then you listen to what they're saying
and like oh i wouldn't said that like
that it's not something that i would
have done but it's not something i would
have done or i feel that it and that's
me and most of the time whenever i go
and i act they like yeah make it you you
know tweak it or whatever what not but
luther and the way egypt alba does it is
very believable aside of the fact that
he ain't got a patty or curry gold in
his uh in his mouth all the time so it's
believable it's still believable and
look maybe it also annoys me a little
bit extra oh i can see that because i
really enjoyed the show honestly it was
such a great especially the first season
with alice morgan right if you guys ever
get a chance to watch it listen you uk
television is fantastic because it's a
lot of it's a show is created by the bbc
it's not for advertising they don't have
to cater to a certain set of rules and
the shows that come out of there are
fantastic and this being one of them and
just to hear the show being tarnished
because it didn't involve racist tropes
or like all this other stuff it's like
did you watch the show can't we just
appreciate it for a great story and not
make everything
about race isn't it possible that
there's a black officer in the uk
specifically a detective who's more
concerned with the facts of the case
rather than always making think
everything about race can't we get a
break at some point and if we do is it a
bad thing
that's my question i guess if if if you
if you watch that show and you're
worried about what he eats and it's not
then then you don't watch this you have
80d
i'm telling you right now that's that's
you're not focusing on what the show is
you're not focusing on what's being said
or whatever what's he eating there just
can you can you there's a plot going on
can you just focus on that or what the
person is saying it's weird i'll just
say no listen i think diversity means
that you're inclusive of all
experiences
not just the one that conforms to your
stereotypes of a specific race that's
what real diversity is it's not that
[ __ ] come on and eat water malone and
[ __ ] shoot guns sideways all the time
that means that if they want to come on
there and just want to be a student
person who doesn't think about race let
them because guess what not every black
person does all the time
and it's nice to be able to take a break
i'm just so exhausted by this constant
need to make everything about that to
make everything about stereotypes so
many people find out oh you're ethiopian
can you do a little shoulder dance it's
like rough chill
cheers chill
oh you're black can you dance bro people
are stupid people don't ask you
yeah oh yeah yeah
oh
yeah
or they're like yo you're ethiopian how
come you're not like [ __ ] skinny
thick whatever bro it's just
you guys are [ __ ] weird you you know
there's all kinds of stereotypes that
you yeah okay the dancing thing it's
just like ruff we get it you could dance
well could you dance no but i could put
this big dick in your mouth
yeah you know
everyone's constantly expecting those
stereotypes so yeah um let us know what
you guys think do you guys think her
comments were warranted or do you
disagree also if you've watched the show
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below we want to hear from you